[Applause]
one word to describe the Oscars magical
good evening it's magic time the
Artistry of making movies and all the
collaboration involved that's magical
only in the movies can we find magic
that starts when the house lights go
dark and we are transported to other
places other times other frames of mind
when I watch a movie I like themes of it
to remain with me and I want to feel
captivated and transfixed by the movie
something to be illumin ated and makes
me feel alive if I can leave with
laughter that's wonderful but I don't
mind tears either since the beginning
movies have connected us with real
people and real events they give us all
a much better understanding of the men
and women who came before us and who
help shape our world it lets me know
that I'm still that feeling empathetic
person and I don't ever want to lose
that they the force that binds us
together that touches the humanity of
all of us if I were to give anyone
advice going to the Oscars for The First
time enjoying the moment our Academy
invites the world to celebrate the magic
of going to the
movies and wear comfortable
shoes